[Music]
is
[Music]
on the front give it up for yourselves
you guys made it to the danny trail
clap it up
yes
beautiful
we're gonna do a [ __ ] show tonight uh
this is other people where we make
people go on dates whether they want to
or not
so some of you might be contestants some
of you might be just watchers but you
never really know so just stay on guard
be anxious and nervous you're doing
great
um
yeah i mean uh this is a great show you
know sometimes we watch people find love
with each other and other times we make
fun of them and make them feel bad for
the way they try to find love with each
other so it's really 50 50 up here um
but uh yeah i'm hans kim i am a regular
on kill tony uh i don't know if this guy
definitely watches
thanks man tell these other people they
have no idea
listen to this guy he makes train noises
as whistles
um
that's an awesome thing that you do i
hope you are signed up we'll get to see
him come up because there's not a lot of
men tonight
uh it's a female it's a convent in here
um
we uh pick one name from each bucket or
two names from the lgbtqia plus bucket
and then we watch people go on a date
for one minute and then we interview
them and get to know them a little bit
better and find out why they said the
things that they said or didn't say the
things they should have said
uh it's a good time i always have a
guest on this show a beautiful beautiful
guest
this beautiful guest is very funny she
is a staple of the austin comedy scene
she travels all over she's a very funny
comedian please get up for leah samson
leah sampson
getting the audience
hot and ready yeah it should be like
little caesars [ __ ]
hello caesars i think that's your rich
this is a very rich crowd wow look at
all these one percentage anybody with uh
highlighting and cardigans is rich to me
so
you have health insurance you're rich to
leah
absolutely we got these two
men and women bucket here you can choose
a woman quality and i'll choose the man
we got gavin d
okay
he's the first state
and lucky victim christie vera
christie oh he's cute
that's all the shoes never mind um he's
wearing sweatpants
he's either russian or serial killer uh
hopefully he's not and you could luckily
he's not in ukraine right he's clearly
not in ukraine that's rather losing
gavin dee and christy going on a date
for one minute what's up what are you on
today
did you make that no
thanks for asking it looks good thanks
um
what are you on
um liquor
weed
on the spectrum
i'm on everything what are you on
i'm on the
fortune 500 list
okay flex and some cocaine
60 uh casio oh that's beautiful
wow he has a nice watch um what should i
ask you
do you take care of your body
no i don't i'm i'm on liquor and smoking
weed of course i don't sorry
do you do you work out
i stopped recently because i was uh
sleeping in a lot
why do you sleep in so much
depression i think um
is that okay
that's super cool yeah i love depressed
girls okay
yeah i wanna i'm eager to please eager
to please yeah 10 brownie points i like
that
how do you please
um probably like just do anything that
you ask or something
give it up for gavin d and christy vera
i think that was a date appropriate
response i think that was either a date
or a caseworker
questioning his client yes
christy are you all right you uh
you you want to be on it you signed up
right no one forced you to sign up
look you know
like being on cocaine is like a wild
ride like there's temporary waves that
you have to
is that bad oh god well try to be a nice
person
sorry
you're not white are you
i'm the white men doesn't count as being
white but i'm just
me i'm 11
not white
yeah
ecuadorians call yourself a lipstick
does she say she's 11 a [ __ ] that she's
uh no i'm 1.3 percent
[ __ ] no just don't it's one more day
let me have this one more day of this
month please let me say it only i can
with this wig
uh this cambodian wig um
you're welcome yeah
yeah no you're welcome i bought it from
the beauty supply store that uh supplies
your college fund
uh please come again
okay boo
we're
uh entertaining herself you i should i
really hate that i said that you were
attractive which i mean people thought
they said hey gavin
thought that bunny was attractive um you
should see me with my serial killer
glasses i got these eight dollar walmart
glasses i look like ted bundy i love it
what was the last time you had um
consensual sex
everything's consensual if you ask
right is he's my father who is this guy
this guy is
and better girls okay is that you're
just your friend yeah we're friends okay
it's just weird that oh it's like you
[ __ ] you don't text your back
here so how could i date her i'm from
right
bro she's not even the zip code she
doesn't hurt her yeah 78702 she's like
9906 something so christy the first
question you asked is what are you on do
you usually find that gets a good
response
um he's sweaty and like a maladjusted
looking so i think that's just his eyes
normally day guys that are on something
to tolerate you or
women in general yeah i think most
people in my circle
you could say men you know
women involved you can say men i'm in
the lgbtq button
have you dated trans person
no have you kind of want to yeah why why
would you date a trans person i wanted
to out like all [ __ ] i wanted a
trans woman because i love titties
i love a woman that looks great and you
love but i love dick that's right and if
she has both
yeah so it's like a build-a-bear you get
to
she's she's she's like a gemini or a
libra i can tolerate you know what i
mean that's oh the star signs
uh gavin what is your star sign
taurus what's your song
serial killer um i'm a cancer oh cancer
okay
he's like where's your birthday cancer
on this date when's your birthday uh
july 2nd very cool i like july birthdays
oh thanks
my brother's july birthday do you have
any siblings
i have a russian little sister russian
i'm wearing green side but that's cool
when we show us your house relationships
if you don't like me interrupting
are you single are you a very single i'm
playing the field really
[ __ ] i can't be dating in austin do you
work in tech or do you know
a body
you want me to give you my card
yeah no no we're not the police
i refred from the app red red fan yeah
the real estate yeah i sell houses nice
for you that's a good job you know you
know go to manchester i can't afford
them but it works christy don't you like
that don't you like a man with a good
job you can buy not a good job you can
buy you more cocaine she's gorgeous
she's had plenty of men with good jobs
she's had plenty of cocaine good job i
feel like any man that makes a job
that's like w-2 worthy he's a good job
you know what yeah
it's w
i have insurance
a lot too much
women have told you that before huh yeah
man ladies
you suck no i'm kidding
i'm just smart welcome to are you white
with leah samson
what is this going to be a game they
play
are you writing every contestant tonight
okay i'm just joking white people are
the worst though black history month let
me have it it's your day it's not mine
okay give it up for gavin d and
christy barra they went on a date thanks
i don't think they're any closer to
[ __ ]
i think i think they're further away i
think you should close your legs when
you sit in front of women that's what i
think
should happen man spreading
that's called a crime let's get off the
stage oh sorry
all right
chrissy vera it's in the hollow garden
let's keep rotating one [ __ ]
where's the woman's spot where's the
where's the oh i put it right here
we're going to get another date
lb and crazy there's already two there's
literally two
women's names in this bucket are you all
that afraid
we need more contestants i'm black and
short i can protect you put your [ __ ]
name in the bucket
come on ladies there's literally only
two things we got damn kiper coming up
oh
jessica
held them
killed them tell them jessica held them
yeah hold them that is a hold them nuts
no i don't know what kind of one that's
the name that's white as [ __ ]
we already know you don't have to play
the game anymore it's very hard to get
hey
jessica and the sam kuiper give it up
for them guys
hello hello hey how are you good you i'm
good what's your name
jessica i'm sam sam nice to meet you
nice to meet you i'm sorry i just have
to call attention this dude had some
dirty ass [ __ ] on his shoes when he
walked up here it's like like dog [ __ ]
and like
bubble gum
okay sorry i got distracted obviously so
what do you do
uh i'm in video production uh i work for
a
marketing and advertising company
and what do you do so i
i'm a video production so like i do
video editing and sound design i also
like
i create commercials i do a lot i'm a
video production manager for a marketing
and advertising company it's a lot of
a lot of [ __ ] i do a lot of [ __ ]
what about you what do you do event
planning event planning like weddings
mostly or
sierras or no a few a few kin scenarios
but mostly of weddings and corporate
events i feel like those have the
biggest budget though like the
quinceanera
all right yeah
i've seen those
quincy era parties man they're lit like
15 year olds are drinking that's all i'm
saying like and everyone knows
everyone's like yes
and ty you're only an adult once give it
up for sam kuiper and jessica
it's like you know he works in the forum
in porn industry and films in ecuador
that's what that whole
whole 15 situation was about i love how
you got down to the brass tacks you're
like okay and what does that actually
mean yeah tell me
man man i will yeah i was trying not to
mansplain
uh
i just said you know the basic
do you always wear [ __ ] like this on the
first day it depends man sometimes i
feel i'm feeling myself right now i'm
feeling myself well you should feel the
woman it's not about you in this
situation you got like me you know what
i mean it's not just about me like yeah
but you're playing too much of you i
don't think sam is feeling many women
these days
it's getting very good all right i'll
tell you
your wardrobe was very sheen i'm taking
a break
i'm doing too good you know it's sunday
it's very sweat shop asian
what kid
sweatshop asian people
send this photo to your cousins and see
if any other failure
i can say that it's my
was that a bong this one is a gong
a bong that's what we smoked in the van
earlier too yeah
um
yeah i mean uh yeah it looks like
something my uh my aunts my relatives
made you know
hidden your player looks like my pants
on day seven after my period
it's really soft very blotchy very brown
full of
uh life
you look like you're trying to hunt moss
in alabama oh that's actually once we
gotta leave him alone we don't want him
to kill himself before they [ __ ] let's
go back to the lady she's the real
victim here
so
how are you doing
great i'm sorry you had to
do this um
it's a joke jessica thank you for
signing up
so uh
dating history are you all like divorced
uh divorced parents jessica has a ring
currently married oh
so he let you at the house good one
the hall pass that's what you're saying
when was your last relationship
uh like before you killed her no no i
didn't kill nobody um today
nah you know sam talked about this he
dated a woman who talked about a lot so
i've had footage i need a woman that
cheated on you
yeah well you were even though i have
though right no i mean like it's not
just me sam's getting sad don't you
don't want saxon i gotta keep saying
this is really good men get cheated on
they do men get cheated on women that
make more more money than them so what
happened
she was making more money than me you're
right uh is that actually true
no i don't think so uh but uh
this this woman was ballsy she's like i
need this man for survival but i'm just
gonna [ __ ] someone else anyway yeah yeah
ballsy that's what you call entrepreneur
yeah
or a [ __ ] you know what i mean so
is that what men want nowadays ladies
they want a freak in the sheets and
i think you've freaked out this mostly
white audience
it's always mostly white here
this is austin we're diverse as [ __ ] are
you talking about us yeah y'all say
there's like a [ __ ] with a and with the
er it's very
different she can say that yeah
none of us
i don't have the
so
so jessica how did you meet your husband
um
thank you
okay eight years ago i got it's like an
ancient history
right like a singles cruise like what do
you mean you're going for that borrower
i'm back in my hometown oh okay because
like i would do a singles cruises
pre-covert i would do a cruise like like
anyway sam would do a cruise pre-coveted
anyways what were you going to say leah
i was gonna say some [ __ ] yeah yeah two
kids oh no
exactly
so you're married you're happy you're
doing this for fun you know this is like
kind of like when white people go to
africa it's like let me just see what
it's like to be poor but
you're just like i want to get off the
registers list so
don't give no don't give me those [ __ ]
me eyes
if you [ __ ] do this one more time
that is very that is so disrespectful
towards the black communication
communication what is that it doesn't
matter
i ask cause you said it you [ __ ] one
light-skinned [ __ ] in fourth grade you
think it looks ridiculous
i'm sick of this [ __ ]
now that i'm hot do you always call me
can i talk to him
the mayor i don't have one of those it's
just a stick of kale greg abbott
with no legs seriously
sam looks like he says n words during
rap songs oh yeah i like lil wayne he
looks like he says the animals
out i mean
no no no you'll never catch me you will
never most of the time you can't you'll
never get it when's the last time you
came this is all your brand what was the
last time you came oh [ __ ] uh not that i
care about them
yeah maybe
how
i jerked off
loser how did you last
came if you know me asking because women
we do come yeah you [ __ ] weirdos we
do come
we come there's one more question that
only leah sampson could ask
[Music]
should i should i know
what's up uh jessica so you met your
husband eight years ago you don't
remember how
eight years ago you came i got it i
didn't know the answer eight years ago
the judicial system was different eight
years ago so it's okay you don't know
there was no me too movement back then
it was just like you married harvey once
no just kidding
so you met your husband you don't
remember do you remember who said who to
what
no who said what to whom what she says
she she said no
that's exactly what and uh when's the
moment was that a little too dark when's
the mo when's the moment that you
realized you were gonna marry him is
there something that he did is there
this section
yeah
wow she's got walls
it's hard to climb because she's not
[ __ ] her well at all clearly that's
the thing about going on dates with
married women it's
it's not as easy as uh the single ladies
but uh sam are you single i'm single
yeah nice i am
32.
you're 40. i'm just 40. chessboard
just eight years ago she met her husband
and eight years ago
last time he came yes
question but right before you met him
was there a weird relationship that you
had just gotten out of right before
i just was a [ __ ] and you were just
happy see ladies if you just [ __ ] be
a [ __ ] you can find love i believe in
that that's not i believe in that that's
the motto for this show what are you
doing if you just trying you can find
dot com no have your fun like
have your fun like have your hot girl
summer all day like have your but have
your outboard summer you know find your
loved ones eventually cut that [ __ ] out
like you're just having fun you do yours
sam
all right
double
which means the black woman should speak
so what i was it's her month
it's almost over though
it's february 27th
um
jessica what did you think about sam
maybe uh nine years ago he could have uh
made you come
i mean the backwards baseball hot yeah
sure you like the jacket you think the
jack is a good choice or do you think he
looks like a spotted uh but it's good
you look like you have asbestos you like
a [ __ ] with eczema
i would know what's with the polka dots
tan and dark polka dots that's not a
good look it looks like uh you look like
a metamucil commercial integrated park i
feel like i look like i have like you
know sunspots like
like scottish
no anyways
so uh
if you were to take jessica on a date
sam where would you go with her
in austin
you like topgolf
yeah
that's where we're going that's where
white people go to date each other
that's where they kick [ __ ] off of
cliffs
only if you get the top floor
if you can afford it you get lucky it's
a hit or miss
all right give it up for sam and jessica
it went on a date
and we're gonna need a man is there a
band that wants to volunteer i'm looking
out
i see a couple men in the audience i'm
bartender i'm ready for that creek
please
we got uh things are getting hostile
anyone any man want to go on a date we
got a fan and a hat over here we got a
man and a hat over here
uh there's a man behind him dude this is
like the one chant
uh we have lisa
aposhu
lisa
are you guys okay are y'all feeling good
her very rare instance
i love her
haircut i like her already don't make us
get sam piper back up here
or even worth gaming
exactly
what there is
don't want to see it
okay lisa and this guy going to the date
nathan lisa and nathan go ahead and date
each other oh we have sneaks what's
going on how are you i'm doing well how
about you my friend what's your name
her name is riley
am i on
i'm on okay her name is riley
lisa nice to meet you uh nathan nice to
meet you you said riley that was you
asked me what my girlfriend's name oh
your girlfriend's safe yes
that's it is going well
are you from austin i am not i'm from
chicago okay well i'm from arizona nice
nice
it's hot it's hot cold and it's a lot of
yeah
we're cold polar opposites here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm surprised
everyone likes me but
let's go for your girlfriend yeah true
true i i use my dog to get her use your
dog too my dog
my dog odin
yep all right end time
give it up for nathan and lisa great
right
so i'm guessing you have a girlfriend
yeah you mentioned a couple times
yeah how did you get baggage
uh that worked we worked at jimmy john's
so jimmy john's night yep yeah both
[ __ ] it's really cute you guys unionized
yeah put that out there
and i don't mean married
wait who are you talking to oh he's
videotaping okay so i was like
jimmy jones yeah they're they're [ __ ]
okay this guy's asking eight inches
eight inches
lisa
how did you meet uh gavin
in san diego in san diego he's a good
photographer he gets the right angles
he's willing to sacrifice for his art
form
hopefully you get to know this table
you're sitting at
all right gavin does not ask for consent
unlike he probably previously stated
so nathan uh how long have you been in a
relationship with uh riley
six years uh
years
jimmy john for six years specifically
what's that i've been working at jimmy
john's for six years we met at jimmy
john's
and then you progress
yeah
no
i'm a trucker now that's why i got the
beard oh trucker
i'm out of control my mother's from
cambodia calm down
her hair is asian uh her hair is from
cambodia what was
my mother is from colombia
and she didn't marry my stepdad for a
green card
so entrepreneurs
that's how you create it
she [ __ ] so i can have a better wig
nathan thank you for being here and not
at the ottawa protests um what is your
favorite part of being a trucker
i don't know dude that's just i just
truck
he's just drunk
there's no favorite part he's [ __ ]
all he does [ __ ] truck
if i was single and looking for a lot
lizards then that'd be fun
you have this seems to be the issue that
i have it's like you're just so gorgeous
but men don't recognize how beautiful
you how great you are so what's
happening with you staying pushed or
are you vegan no i'm not oh
why there is what are you up here for
you to be single you were gorgeous you
were beautiful
gavin d
oh it's
no i heard trafficking in russia is wild
but you are
free here at the cricket cave on sixth
street red river oh wait we got a
trucker right here he can take you
anywhere yeah
within state lines punch some air holes
i'll tell you one thing a wall doesn't
face him okay
he's in it
wait are you married no i'm not
uh
question
what's the worst date y'all have ever
been on besides this one probably
because we're here
no offense to you i'll let you answer
first she has a girlfriend you can make
him cry
first date well probably this one yeah
like not whatever this is what happened
this shows how he consents
what happened before you came here
uh she came
no
i did oh no
sorry
enjoy it now because if you're in a
relationship it's not gonna happen they
have to watch and it gets weird
it's like you have cable where i was at
like earlier today
yeah
drinking drinking here 6th street e6 i
have no idea actually e6
okay somewhere and then i go out and i
get a beer handed to me and nice that's
a good vibe
they do karaoke there every tuesday with
another hour
all i can say is when i say masturbation
did i say masturbation when i said
masturbation and liquor you smell it the
hardest so that just kind of
shows the purpose you have uh and
you have a confidence i don't matter at
all to you
speaking of wigs lisa you have a very
good hair he has great [ __ ] hair you
can sell it i want to buy the dog
have you ever cut your hair really short
or to glue it really long um this is the
longest it's been i've gone
this is the haircut that i will like try
to get before i call the cops you know
what i mean like i want
i won't protect you again
or the lisa i want them to show up you
know
so how many relate uh when's the last
relate what's the last relationship
you've been in uh last one was three
years ago
and uh how did you meet this strapping
lad uh
friends through friends
you seem like you have a lot of friends
i feel like she you'd make a good friend
you seem like you're that's what i'm
saying like she seems like she's easy to
be with oh yes and not also i'm like
well the whole [ __ ] is good but like not
on some ho [ __ ] like you're easy to be
with like you're not gonna go through
the phone you're not gonna you know you
just don't care because
yeah because that's just that makes
weird things it's awkward between your
boyfriend and your husband and it's like
you don't want that [ __ ] drama and i
[ __ ] i feel you absolutely this is how
leah tells white women that she likes
them yes
i think she likes you i do i do
i do i want to hang out with you before
march 1st all right sweet do you have a
type do you think that there's like a
type that you look for
everybody says my friends are just like
i don't know what your type is whoever
you dated like sports
she's traumatized well here's the thing
all over the board i don't know
i'm traumatized you ever dated a black
man i have not leah is he black
leah you could introduce her to someone
well once i found my father i'll
introduce them oh
you want a stepmother i will i do with
that kind of hair absolutely i do i need
some structure in my life um
i've only dated one black you know
what's crazy cons what i dated a black
man uh consensually and
hopefully
okay and what's crazy we met on a show
like this i was performing at the
houston improv and you know ruining
other people's lives and he was like
[ __ ] yeah i want that and he like
approached me three years later we dated
um but he sucked uh he was black but not
really black because he wore like
chubbies like american flag chubbies
so which was like role play was fun
because like our role played to be like
employed and he really played to be
black and it was just a good time
but um he cheated on me but the moral of
the story is um none of this matters
yeah it's just people
[Laughter]
fine it's okay he was a firefighter too
he was a firefighter before the nazi
applauses he was a firefighter kevin is
a nazi yeah hello
well who else wears adidas track suits
uh how are you two weeks ago no he was
you know he was a firefighter which is
why it's okay that he cheated because
his job was to um
save hoes and put out
seen the flame
that's why i [ __ ] with you thank you
leah i might let you see it nipple i
might get to say the n word tonight no
no i'm just kidding with the nipple
don't worry
i'll show you the photo of a nipple that
didn't get a lot of likes on my only
fans so it's kind of like when like
dunkin donuts doesn't sell all their
donuts and they give the leftovers to
them i'll take it yeah yeah yeah you
better
leftovers
but uh leah sampson follow her on only
fans subscribe she's got an only fans
bro [ __ ] you seem sad and tired do i
all here
leah's attacking the audience i'm not
i'm just trying to figure out where
they're coming from i want to know like
what's going on what y'all feeling what
y'all thinking what's happening you got
a [ __ ] there's a bathroom
they changed them back to women's and
men's so you have privacy now you won't
get pregnant this time like what's going
on
i'm here for y'all leah wants to get to
know you hopefully more of you will sign
up and uh
be able to get you know wait this isn't
the end of the show is it no
okay because like i said i showered for
this [ __ ]
um yeah i mean uh
this is a great uh experience because
it's like being at a movie theater that
yells back at you yeah
it's like watching like a tyler perry
film
nathan
congratulations to you and your
girlfriend
um i hope she doesn't come to her senses
anytime soon and you is that riley i'm
over there
she's back in arizona she's in arizona
finishing up school so you look like you
eat [ __ ] and go is it okay like you're
just so that's exactly me you're so cute
so cute
do you need water
and then you look like you know eat my
[ __ ] you know
i like both of y'all are not good
together but separate crushing it
love that love that looks like he ate so
much [ __ ] that stuck to his face
that's what you call traveling abroad
he's a trucker
uh
nathan um
so you're trucking what are you hauling
dope
propane and accessories propane and
accessories don't crash blue rhino so
hank hill over here um how do you bring
bobby hill bobby hill how do you like uh
how do you like the trucking business
are you afraid of uh tesla making you uh
obsolete with the auto driving
no i mean i've only been doing this for
a month two months but i mean i wouldn't
you've been mexican for two months
i think that's more of a white
occupation
right let me know uh
let me know which truck's yours so
guess george lopez
am i about to get blown up
lisa what do you do for
work and accounting
super interesting that that fits your
hairstyle does it that makes a lot of
sense
yes you have the hairstyles like i don't
have the credit for the home but you're
gonna make some calls like you're gonna
you're looking you're gonna make some
calls and you're gonna try to you look
like uh you look like you could play the
love interest in a steve carroll movie
steve carell
you're uh you look very wholesome
like uh like
it's my second language
i love you
wholesome but yeah
yeah but you're really like get your
[ __ ] and then you're like yeah give me
more
that's a good observation you look like
you get bad sex because you want it you
know like sex because yeah you know like
i know this is going to be bad but
i'll mix that up you know like because
you have that much power who wants to
see lisa go on a real date with a single
man with balls no just kidding uh fuzzy
why don't you get on up here and go on a
date with the beautiful lisa
here he comes more torture from
comedians sir
nathan thank you so much for coming up
it's not that you didn't expect to come
up but you're
witnessing with mental illnesses
thank you so much it says first time on
screen give it up for game day
you can't be that good looking on the
stage
and just go no there's fuzzy killed you
hilarious
tony thank you lisa
he likes white women so this should go
really good
so do i what i don't know the premise of
the show we go on a date you're on a
date i'm not good at this how long have
you been in austin uh since april day
since friday friday yeah did you move
here no visiting i'm looking for
something more long term so
it's going to be quick
okay i'm also actually okay with cats 24
hours yeah
uh where are you from chicago i'm from
madison wisconsin you've ever been hey
santa what do you think of madison it's
all right yeah chicago's all right
no chicago is way better than madison
it's a good pizza
yeah
not not deep dish do you ever you ever
go to giordano's no
okay uh that's like a tourist thing
yep uh
they're done
what uh how about those packers not uh
not a big uh cheese and beer
nope not in that no
i'm going i'm more into going on dates
with a beautiful woman from chicago
so i'm right on my element right now
there you go
good enough for funs he killed you and
lisa
thank you guys thank you i like that
exciting i like this
right now in front of all of us
yes please [ __ ] in front of all of us
uh fuzzy you went with the flattery at
the end yeah yeah first i thought you
weren't interested because you weren't
making any eye contact but then i
realized that's how you express your
interest yeah yeah yeah well i like when
you probably playing hard to get
i like he was like i like some more
long-term i was like way to slide and
arrange marriage you know
yeah just so you know
my parents are never going to know about
you
right right right
neither were the simpsons anymore they'd
be in that they've been that that
doesn't exist anymore lisa have you
dated a indian man ever
still have that message pakistani okay
24 hours
all right you should uh date uh indian
or slash pakistan they have reliable
businesses they're they're in small
business so you know they have a stable
income and uh they don't hit you that
much yeah
no i'm kidding
predictable if they're celebrating
ramadan you can be free from your [ __ ]
be eaten until 8 pm
it's a good time for everyone a muslim
joke that's a great muslim joke same
thing i didn't get enough love that was
really really funny thank you
i'm really really talented
and she's giving all the women on stage
props
i'm just keeping my options open i don't
know how she feels about me so far
as you should yeah have you ever dated a
anglo-saxon cocktail
i've only had like one real girlfriend
in my whole life uh and she was white
your mom is not your girlfriend you need
some rope
who have you had sex with uh
like the whole list the one girlfriend
is she white is she the first who did
you [ __ ] sensual when you're married
uh her name was hayley byrne she was
just it was third grade she was my only
girlfriend third grade you [ __ ] and
never played
four days lasted four days she kissed
sam caravello and then it was over so
sam has a bigger dick than yours but
thank you [ __ ] i think you guys had more
confidence back in the day
maybe not [ __ ] i'm not a virgin if you
haven't had the question
we thought he was going to blow us all
up
why are we ignoring the question
[ __ ] third grade
this is like euphoria
euphoria
do you like euphoria they're doing drugs
the budget is low
where we were still praising bush
you kind of look like sugar extra on
you look like the owner of the bodega
they get drugs from and
this guy pretty sure
thank you look at gavin he's not made
himself home and and this couple's table
because they're raping that number are
you guys okay i want to say raven you
guys know that's a joke
send out an episode that's the guy you
came with here's nathan signing himself
up again
couldn't get enough he's signing up his
girlfriend riley yeah dude
is riley here that dude's hot as [ __ ]
he's in arizona he's here good for you
[ __ ] to let her boyfriend embarrass one
with another [ __ ] like that
that's a strong woman
sign some someone up somewhere
uh
so what were you guys saying i was just
saying the dude that she came here with
is really hot
so
those are two very different i feel like
gavin would look really good in a frat
house but here's he's out of place he's
a normal society where his douchiness uh
grabbing looks like the type of dude
that's like bro if she still has the
pulse there's no case
that's got to come from a real cool bro
bro that was very accurate very good
instagram got hacked she'll be more
worried about that than you know what
really happened
oh straight fire from leah sampson
i guess i'm telling you that's
weird oh hell no
you racist piece of [ __ ] our sound guy
is from louisiana
deep in the swamps
uh lisa where uh
when did you come to austin you're from
chicago chicago i came here on friday
and i leave tomorrow oh yeah this is
right i am okay
so now how do you like the freedoms you
know no one made you get a vax card
no it's really well it's pretty legit
there
what do you mean legit like like they uh
not like it spread throughout the city
like we do
yeah
welcome to texas where even germs are
freedom
no i feel like because the dick in
chicago has standards in here they know
well it's cold so you know like germs
don't all shriveled
chlamydia does not exist in 30 degree
weather
have you had dick since you've been here
yes
well that was quick
welcome to wasn't an attractive woman
was it good because it was here
gavin how come it
it was
was it because he responded to your text
yeah
[Laughter]
i keep looking at you i feel like you
have a story to tell me we'll talk about
it's going to be like therapy hour you
should respond to when women say no
that's what you should respond
damn yeah rape crop victims
we got them too it's fine
you ever rape anybody me no
cool
anyways
fuzzy
what are you up to nowadays ah good time
things are good things are good just you
know
open mics
shows whenever i can get them
let's uh not talk about comedy on a date
that usually does not or rain ask me
what i was up to
i want to
lisa have you ever dated a comedian
not
what do you think it'd be like
probably not funny
have you ever dated a guy with no bed
frame
and bad jeans and shoes yes they're the
comedian um
i just like to say i have a bed frame
but i don't i don't have a box spring
[ __ ] so hard it's really embarrassing
no i'm really not that's a this is my
stick you guys that makes you [ __ ]
more like shut up and call her a [ __ ]
lovely woman i'm happy she's got this
gavin guy they look like they're great
together and uh we're not together a
girlfriend no
she's very adamant they're not together
she said she [ __ ] the
annoying
okay y'all are [ __ ] cool yeah well
how do you know gavin but here's the
thing if she's [ __ ] him really the
ball like she's [ __ ] yeah it's this is
turning into like therapy
a little bit it's free so you don't have
to answer anything you don't want to
answer
just well here's a good mouthpiece
he's very nice guy yes
okay
absolutely not
the point he has no personality but he
eats her out really well that's just
kind of what this whole situation is
they [ __ ] they have good sex and he
sucks that's just kind of
what it is right
the crowd is on gavin's side
tonight you know it's joe you know this
is a [ __ ] comedy club you [ __ ]
weirdos like
gavin uh
gavin looks like a smurf or something
you look like you eat good butthole
you do you really do that's what they
teach you in the frats either or russia
he looks russian
are you putting it in the butthole i
mean they're pretty famous in the
okay does he eat your ass
he deserves
lisa i'm sorry that uh
i feel like i have to be the feminist
here and
yeah i'm out of control
let's uh let's ask some personal
questions to fuzzy i feel like he could
take it go ahead yeah
fuzzy have you ever uh had your [ __ ]
fingered or licked fingers never licked
fingers oh okay question
you're
religious you're still a virgin
not a ver uh [ __ ] version sure to
being licked thank you
i would be disgusted if a girl went back
there i am
i my name is fuzzy i'm hairy as [ __ ]
sure
that's what i'm saying i don't want that
let's just go get some ice cream watch a
movie so you're okay with the woman that
doesn't shave you you will go down on
the woman it doesn't show i don't know
uh i'm like so hairy i don't have a
right to yeah it's a little hypocritical
yeah yeah okay okay like what the [ __ ]
no right right
ladies he has low standards
actually have extremely high standards
and ladies she's better than
all women in this
place
i think she's great if she wasn't with
gavin dude totally
and it's all jokes you [ __ ]
conservatives
we love that this is happening that's
what you do you [ __ ] are beautiful
you get a good haircut you [ __ ] come
to austin texas you get great hair and
you go back to where you [ __ ] came
from where
that's what you do give it up for the
lisa story
that's what you do
lisa came she's welcome
and in 10 years [ __ ] i'm a vote for you
for mayor and that's just what's going
to happen [ __ ] yeah i'm going to replace
laurie lightning exactly easily easily
it's going to be uh laurie
when guys do shits like right now but
when a girl does something it's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm a [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and i make more money than you
[ __ ] [ __ ] sorry i'm coming tonight
you're crying
she's not personal for me i'm sorry he's
coming every day it's not no eight years
[ __ ] with uh deserve that
even if it's from this psychopath you
deserve to come yes
it's just the weekend it's fine
you are irreplaceable
i think gavin is so cool let's go dude
dude he's [ __ ] chilling here being
high but me and you should chill
something more fun than the audience
what happened is it's like an aaa like
it was like a group sheet you got to
sign off when you're like for aaa or
what's your pre sent you here what's
happening
it'll be funnier
i think we have to pay the audience
fuzzy when's the last time you had sex
uh two days ago whoa
i thought you were a loser i'm not you
would think i was back home in wisconsin
i think you're a loser
you
she's turning into bernie mac
uh the other black one that died i'm
afraid of you mother talking with you
guys
she's reading my audience beautiful with
a cardigan y'all got upset i don't know
what's going on for me this is
technically a hate crime
yeah bullying no nobody we gathered them
here too
for liberal uh
reparations i was like i'm praising this
white woman forgetting
orgasms
okay how did you meet this person you
had sex with two days ago we used to
work together at a call center in
wisconsin i was back in wisconsin
visiting home that was very much your
jimmy john's and uh yeah
tell you what the text was freaky fast
come on what are we doing guys
let's go hey
uh i'm good at wordle what's the longest
you've had you've given her
the longest i've giving head no your dad
what's the longest you've given ahead i
don't know 10 15
[ __ ] yeah minutes damn
that's like a
did she come
she she pretended to at least i don't
know what actually happened well we do a
lot of
things um
so fuzzy uh two days ago you uh came to
i feel like you'd be good at sex because
you'd be like uh you work at a call
center and you're like how can i help
you
[Music]
very
customer friendly always thinking
consumer first yeah i thought you'd be
good at sex because you seem a little
autistic and i feel like autistic men
are very good at what they put their
mind to thank you thank you right hans
i'll take it
we're very single-minded every [ __ ]
just talked about [ __ ] you it's
always a good review i'm like because
it's [ __ ] autistic episode
yeah
i'm gonna [ __ ] money goes a long way
hey these strippers no um
i uh i think autistic people are uh you
know the best the new
the new thing it's like tech talk you
gotta try an autistic person
autistic men are are um
what's the word y'all are very like i'm
going to get this [ __ ] done
yes yes y'all are autistic men are very
goal-oriented they're like i'm gonna
[ __ ] make this [ __ ] bust you know
yeah that's what i'm thinking
gotta make this girl plus man
and then i'm gonna buy her
antidepressants with my benefits
samson
perfectly describing they don't care
about me thank you for that that's this
is just an infomercial for my dick right
now um
for uh
fuzzy kill g and lego
thank you guys so much in another world
lisa in another world
you still have a chance she openly
stated how much she hated gavin
go for it fuzzy
now only if she's done of course
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
up
[Music]
go ahead and date
i openly don't do well in front of
crowds
but i'm gonna just
lock this part out
and we'll see what happens
i feel the same way i dig your shirt
thank you
um i got it today i don't i don't
actually know what it is
i changed in my car it's a surfer dude
you know what you tell me what do you
see i see a surfer dude and like a
turtle i feel like it's open to
interpretation yeah it's like a picasso
or it's kind of like her hat yeah yeah i
was gonna say that down there too i dig
the hat yeah i like the alien on your
hat
80 different hats that's the only thing
i do is i get different types of hats
what do you do for work i don't have a
lot going on i just have different types
of hats what do you do for work uh i buy
houses so i'm the opposite of this guy
you buy houses i buy houses not sell
houses yeah okay and i put them all in
airbnb
smart it's cool like decorating them
because i get a do a different theme for
each one so that's kind of cool do you
have an airbnb in austin uh no austin
has really
it's boring but austin has really the
lacks str i'm in need of one tonight
that's why i asked i don't have anything
end time
give it up for uh adam pond then maddie
loves the uh
i love the boring str time i didn't want
to go into that there was like actually
they always say close strong and uh you
really got the vaginas yeah i know
talk i
i figured that was going to kind of drop
it but you know i'm willing to take a
chance you know adam
chances
what is
uh
where are you visiting from actually i
live in san marcos oh okay
yeah very lack of fdr laws there as well
you know white men like you exclaimed me
really happy y'all are so funny why am i
like you're like oh yeah i [ __ ] built
skateboards for a living but my family
comes from plantations money yeah that's
like it's always like there's some money
there's money behind there's no money
behind a struggle my dad was so just sad
no my dad was so freaked he did it he
literally didn't say let me just say he
he made one play or two of toilet paper
and no one liked one
no oppression
thank you
i know oppression he went to the wendy's
congratulations and got that for him and
poured him into the large ketchup bottle
yes queen
he's describing how his dad got
condiments
he's describing why his dad didn't be a
white man properly that's what the [ __ ]
his dad is describing
what's the most uh poor thing you've
done have you ever taken toilet paper
that shirt
um
if i'm being honest i was at a bar
a little bit inebriated and i drank
someone's glass from a different table
judge me or don't but that's what
happened
it happens
that sounds frugal yeah this guy uh
probably knows all the laws that go into
that it's making me wet over here no
it's probably bad that i said that with
all these regulations
no no they're okay
so what do you think about what do you
think about adam pond's hat hobby are
you into hats is that like kind of your
thing um no it's not my kink okay i mean
that's the type of hat you get after you
get your belly button pierced that clear
it's kind of a go home souvenir
i have another one with an open sign on
it i was going to wear that it just it
just says open it like the chinese
restaurant yeah it opens you look you
guys
wait why is it specifically a chinese
restaurant aren't there they usually
have the open signs there but
a lot of businesses are
i agree i think that what you said was
discriminatory sponsor
i think surviving i think he thinks
asians have good business sense
we do not true yeah honestly if y'all
what's your dating history
um
oh wait no what were you gonna say no i
said it white wrong
white dating history two mexicans
she is from san marcos
i'm from san antonio
is actually appropriate oh
maybe they're circumcised or no of
course not
yes they were
so back to these mexicans yes how was
that um
great
do you want details yes
please sober and mentally healthy
i don't really have any i don't think
what was um
a lot of side of guac with these details
yeah
um what was uh
either one what was something that one
of them did sexually where you were like
yo
i'm not going to call the cops on this
one
she's thinking
i am thinking but can i choose not to
answer
she's pleading the fifth it's just that
i don't know any of you
i hope you don't mind that i don't want
to share my personal well
i'm going to jump in here i feel like a
burden
i've never had
ever in
is she grabbing through her own legs or
is she twisting around legs both legs
that's only happened once she's doing
what with my flags psa okay
it's not to make you feel uncomfortable
i'm not uncomfortable don't say anything
that you don't feel comfortable selling
but i guess i will say this um
[Music]
is there something that one of these
hispanic men did to you
whether it was like uh just
nice just as a man that you that kind of
like made you be like wow this is
different this is nice this is you know
making sure i come first
okay right that's nice wouldn't we agree
i wouldn't wish that would be mandatory
right
well
it's not always the thing
it's always hispanic it's always
mexicans or the ugly ones then make sure
you come first it's always
it's never impossible i got you it's
never in between it's never [ __ ] in
between that's usually the man that
comes first and then they send for their
wife and children right and they say
make me a sandwich
well i was that was a bad joke
well at least no you're good again
um so you dated two mexicans you've
dated how many mexicans
uh three
three three mexicans he's asking you and
you attacked me before and after they
were like legal date uh wait what
legal family it's fine you weirdo how
many green cards woman have you [ __ ]
uh one her name was juicy that was a
mistake shippers don't count yeah yeah
i'm not counting her real name wasn't
juicy but um
i figured that out later [ __ ] black
women are just named after capri suns
yeah
that's that's what it is
i'm named
her real name was adriana she didn't
want to tell me
i don't
are you [ __ ] psychopath we all have
our own ways you know
this one is saying to ukraine right now
we still have our own ways
everyone's rushing
um that's awesome you know two of the
whitest people i know have dated five
mexicans total that's very important i
have a question about their
texas of y'all
both aeropostale t-shirts that's
we should
so maddie where did you get your shirt
at um a thrift store nice and it's like
a rorschach roarshark
um you know what i like i said i do not
know um
it's one of mexico i bought it off the
street today is sunday
market
it looks way better than sam's jacket at
least i feel like we're interested in
the shirt than anything else their
frugality is really the shirt she means
sure yeah so adam what's the question
that you want to ask when when's the
next time you're gonna make out with
kaylee
kaylee okay irs killed
on the kill on the kill tony kaylee funk
the the stripper from bailey funk red
road is that your mother because no no
no i watched
tony and when i saw you are you worried
about what if you [ __ ] sarah i'm very
curious
i'm just asking
leah's gonna [ __ ] everyone in this room
check under your chair have asthma
condom i have asked anybody i have asked
it will be consultable insurance have
asthma no health insurance there will be
consent
it's like there will be blood but uh
give it up for maddie and adam pond
they wanted a date with each other
pond is in here again amanda pond we got
amanda pawn coming up
we got amanda pond oh amanda pond just
walked away
[Music]
who's going through a rough time right
now in the relationship let's let's dr
feel this [ __ ] real quick
wants to come up
we need a couple coming up
okay oh man beautiful beautiful woman
hey you hi
hi
no individual
wait would you like my stage
come on baby
get your cat
that's like a prize of the past baby
okay come here y'all both when they come
out another nation y'all come in stage
all three of y'all this is austin boyle
emirates [ __ ] let's [ __ ] play all
three of you hoes
respectfully
yeah what was your name nicole paul he
has a good handshake
so what's up what's this
so
um where are you from uh from florence
texas lawrence texas yeah uh it's about
45 minutes northwest of here northwest
i'm getting like east texas five yeah so
most of my most my family's from
louisiana and oh thanks texas yeah no
really really where we're at
um
shreveport but new orleans randazzo is
my last name
okay
okay yeah yeah uh so i'm uh my uh my
east texas is uh saint augustine
beaumont
okay and uh what is that it smells like
somebody's trying to like break in here
with tinfoil dude what the [ __ ] all
right cool i guess that's over um
and then uh my louisiana kinfolk are
from uh manny and uh shreveport so okay
there you go cool yeah common bonds
there okay how long have you been in
austin uh five years okay it's a decent
amount of time yeah so i mean i've lived
here all my life i was born in west
texas and then uh i grew up kind of
central texas moved around a lot
yes yeah i was born at big big national
hospital were you really yeah for real
i go there a lot for work okay what do
you do out there for work i'm an
elopement photographer i'm an adventure
photographer so if anyone wants to elope
i can sign your marriage oh yeah
time give it up for seeing daniel
we all saw them go on a date you guys
did a lot of geography there yeah man we
went through the ringer it was awesome
yeah you guys went all over this it
wasn't awkward there was an awkward
moment in that that's really cool yeah
yeah y'all talked about every place that
why people get hung
really
what did you just say white people get
hung black people get home why did you
have to bring that up i don't feel like
it's still one day left of family i know
i hear you girl i hear you get it out
while you can you know that's awesome
well they don't scare me
why is it right it's not racist
who's that racist you said it was racist
you said you're in your head it was
racist lee i don't want to do this
dean you brought a date tonight right
yeah
no i do i i uh i was walking up here to
tell you that i did bring a date tonight
uh
and then he said you should just hop up
on here
no i didn't say that i just said it's
awkward
are you sad that dean's on a date right
now i just [ __ ] have a point
that's awesome no pictures that's saving
his ego
yeah he's not actually dating he's like
just seeing her we just made her bar
she's really cute she just comes to your
shows at the creek no she's never we've
never met before we met with latchkey at
the another hour concert
oh hell yeah dude i don't know what that
means over audience members thank you
for supporting the show dude i said hans
kim's doing a show i'm just [ __ ]
surprised dude he's a hilarious comedian
y'all check out his youtube it's really
fun i also got a tick tock out there he
does have a tick tock
dana
what are we doing here dude
getting over here how's your day open
mike uh
you uh
yeah you uh talk a lot about texas and
uh yeah because you're from here you
feel like you have a home field
advantage what do you talk about when
you go to like new york or l.a
uh if i'm like trying to date or if i'm
trying to like talk to women yeah do you
think about texas i got uh i have a
mullet and i drive race cars
and that you guys have those in new york
so what do you say to people i don't
have to prove it if i'm in new york but
i got like instagram stories and i'll be
like hey i'm a race car driver
and that usually helps you just show up
white with a mullet that's enough you
basically
dance really well i dance that's my move
if i need to like go with your best
dancer can
all right
this isn't
the best we're going to get evening is
actually a very good dancer
luke bryan for the cause they're going
to do some texas two-step
look at that this is stockholm syndrome
this is how
she's like yeah it is
they're already doing it
because she is sleepy now she's not
[ __ ] home
i hate that big
she doesn't quit
she's built like a hog [ __ ] that [ __ ]
she killed my dog
what up bird do you
feel that
according
and leah sampson provided the lyrics he
stopped by southwest in the houston
houston radio
are you saying country music is
formulaic enough for them that was
really cute that was really great you
guys are great
so uh how do you feel the uh the texas
country you know this is uh is awesome
but you've lived in texas all your life
people you were yeah
no no pittsburgh city east texas where
did you stay in colorado basically went
on a date with the state of texas
tonight
i'll take it dude yeah i like how you
were like that you lived in texas it's
kind of like what like predators say
interesting
like yeah i don't turn on it so it was
not like i said nothing needed you all
night
or do i suck that much no it's if some
if a white guy comes on stage with a
mullet and does a two-step you gotta
call him racist
you can't not a problem we're trying to
witness we would adjust convenience we
just don't know what we're doing wrong
convenient it's out here dean is a very
nice guy that was
[ __ ] with me and i'm pretty black he's
pretty black oh your family owns black
hair chain stores but we're not no at
the same time at least we don't own
black people like dean does
uh
what is going on dude i thought this
would help my career but this is really
hurting my it's really hard my game
don't worry why would you take her
if you were to go on a date with
courtney p terry's where was your friend
let me ask you because i was thinking
about this
uh you have a boyfriend right i do so
tell me if this would be a good idea to
take another girl okay
i'm really good at dating coaching
people yeah let's do that can we try
this from a dating show to you coaching
me where to take this girl on my next
day yeah okay cool okay let's do it
so i don't know much about this girl
okay i just met her just just a little
while ago like how long ago like three
hours ago oh all right dance with her at
another bar okay
and i didn't get her number but i got
her instagram
okay my phone was dead sorry to give her
mine so anyway okay that's where we're
at
so i was thinking uh i haven't been uh
i'm really good at putt-putt okay so and
i haven't ever been on like an actual
puppy
right so i was thinking i would take her
to putt-putt golf and then maybe go to a
like a steak dinner or something
that's it that's pretty sink combo ted
bundy so it's like fancy and silly so we
silly first and then we can and then
once
out then we can go have like a good
conversation and that's incredible
empty king i like you dude this guy's
[ __ ] awesome hell yeah dude he
plucked wait i was talking
to you
right
there
no man dudes i can't wait to let's do a
shot after this dude
yeah dude no and then they're all
laughing giggly and then when you get to
you can get serious and get like more
like romantic
you guys both kind of [ __ ] get paid
can we
so this has been a lot of fun
but you didn't tell me what you thought
was the last time you sucked the day
well no dude why would you say that i've
never done it what if that was like the
moment that i remembered that i had you
know of course i was like that was like
childhood trauma that would be terrible
bumble
who laughed right there you'd look at
last approach it's actually an austin
company
people that was funny
she has icloud storage
[ __ ] nobody
what is she saying she has icloud
storage android you wouldn't know but
i have an iphone and i don't know how to
work it so with generation
12.
you started i don't believe you it is
that's a 12. that's pretty good for a
guy with a mullet
this mullet looks like my [ __ ] i'm not
impressed and i don't put a case on it i
feel like that's bad no case you're a
[ __ ] second is that a kind of thing
yeah i feel like i'm living dangerous
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] i
don't know how to hold on to [ __ ] yeah
i'm not taking the up charge i pay for
the [ __ ] insurance on purpose if it
[ __ ] up i'll take it in but
i don't know why i got so aggressive
about that
right ukraine
why do you bring up ukraine
because black people don't think that
black people know about history
russia ukraine and george bush a lot
people think i'm smart do you understand
how no they don't it's being black in
america people don't think kanye west is
smart i think he is
i don't [ __ ] white women he's [ __ ]
white women inappropriate off of black
culture so i don't know what that's like
i don't know what's going on i think i
took a black woman's weak and it makes
you sweat that's okay you're for sure
how are you doing what uh how well are
you regretting bringing your date on a
date are you
going to be right on stage no i think it
went i think it went well
yeah you uh two
two steps you helped me in the advice
okay
that's what i'm waiting for y'all didn't
let her answer so answer like uh chill
like maybe like picnic things like
arbitrary drawers yeah like homelessness
all right you want me to do a picnic
thing
i'm not gonna pick anything kind of guys
though y'all
steakhouse she's gonna not know like
what to wear oh okay that's true i don't
think about that kind of [ __ ] that's why
that wouldn't work dude
you tell her what to wear
okay go to like a food truck area after
the putt-putt and she [ __ ]
well hold on hold on this is what she's
saying she said go to can you
how many girls here are [ __ ] you
right now like 10 bundy she's sitting
there like uh me [ __ ]
he's like
dating
uh so
what did you suggest besides putt-putt
like a food truck trailer area something
more low-key
like an awesome like putt-putt and then
food truck yeah
peter pan what does people think
justification like
when you keep taking it back to that
every time
yeah
like let's invade this really poor good
old neighborhood
you know
yeah
it's not gonna be a weird time when they
like
i don't know when food trucks start
moving are you right next society no
it's dean by the way and dean i'm not
going to pull my feet out of the crocs
i think we got a pedicure like two weeks
ago so it might not be bad
oh it's a little black it's a little
black
oh yeah
you have a shout out my show is that
what you said no i said i'll probably
ask you to be on one of your shows oh
yeah yeah that's all good reasons for
sure
grapes that wine would turn into
hennessy
all right that's pretty pimpin i'll take
that pretty pimpin watch your mouth this
is my mom turn into some redneck merlot
is that y'all's word you have to flip
mcbride is the pimpest [ __ ] in
the whole [ __ ]
scene right now thank you dude talking
to me it's a good shout out no danny
mcbride isn't lifting his face a wig
that looks like you so i [ __ ] dude
he's bounding down
righteous gemstones righteous gems
that's a pimping [ __ ] dog he's pretty i
do have pretty eyes i do have pretty
eyes i know it
i try not to be too cocky about it but
they are really pretty no you don't you
always your shoes say otherwise do they
they're just confident
that's a laugh
got those eyeshadows
yeah there was a bad person are you
happy you came out tonight
i am this has been unique this is a
unique experience i was just thinking
about i was like i wasn't even gonna
come over here we were gonna go
somewhere else and i was like hans is
doing that show that might be fun
and this has been a good time now you're
here hello dean uh thank you for coming
thank you for having me thank you say to
uh courtney any last words to this girl
with a boyfriend yes
uh if you and your boyfriend would like
to come i run a show here on wednesdays
it's called best of luck you're
promoting your own stuff
oh yeah dude thank you so much
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out you can follow leon
anything you want you can follow me on
only fans and you can follow me on
officially samson on instagram i'm a lot
meaner online uh in twitter how'd you
like the dates tonight i loved it it was
very traumatizing it brought me back to
my first years in college uh
i think you eventually won this audience
over it's like a woman i think they're
scared of me but i think after the show
they're gonna be like can i touch your
hair and i'm gonna be like absolutely
it's gonna be a good time i think ladies
don't ask to touch your hair it's
february it's black history month this
one was cheap it's okay keep the music
going and uh
my filmmakers are coming out
[ __ ] having the rest of the night
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for watching go to hello
is
[Music]
organisms
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
move
you